as we've talked about in multiple videos
Christianity is a religion that grew out
of the fringes of the Roman Empire it
starts as a Jewish sect in Judea and
Galilee with the teachings of Jesus and
his early ministry but it's important to
keep in mind at the time of Jesus's
crucifixion around 30 C II he only had
at most we're talking about the hunt in
the hundreds of followers but in other
videos we talked about his apostles who
start spreading the faith not only to
other Jews but also to non-jews to
Gentiles we talked about Emperor Nero
and his famous purges of Christians in
particular you have the famous Roman
fire or the fire of Rome in 64 C II that
Nero blames on Christians and he uses
this to do significant purge in Rome
many historians believe that the
Apostles Peter and Paul were killed
during those purges this is a painting
of Nero using Christians lighting them
alive to punish them for that fire now
other imperial acts that continue to
have a significant effect effect on this
very early Christian Church we talked
about the the destroying of the Second
Temple in Jerusalem in 70 CE II and
that's under the reign of this patient
and this is of course is a very
significant event for the Jewish people
but it also has a significant effect on
Christianity because remember
Christianity was really centered at
Jerusalem it was a sect of Christianity
or it was it Scott starts as a sect of
Christianity but now with the
destruction of the temple the Jews were
dispersed from Jerusalem and this and
and so are many of these early
Christians and so the centers of
Christianity became throughout the
empire places like Antioch and you
continue to have a discomfort with
Christians especially as it became more
and more in number and they started to
have more and more power and you here
you have these people who refused to
obey the the Roman gods to do their
rituals to worship the Roman gods and
remember even there was Emperor worship
here and the issue was
more so than even the Jewish people who
to certain degree kept to themselves
these Christians were missionaries they
were spreading their faith to Roman
citizens families were being split apart
where some decided to become Christians
and no longer follow these Roman
practices and so you have these various
persecutions in these various purges and
they get more and more significant as
you go into the second and even to some
degree in the third century as
Christians become more and more
prominent and more and more in number
remember to have this missionary zeal
and it really becomes a significant
purge under the reign of Diocletian in
previous videos we talked about
Diocletian he's the one that famously
split the empire between east and west
but he's also famous for his purge of
the christians the most extreme
state-sponsored purges of Christians in
the Roman Empire but what's interesting
is right after or shortly after those
purges we're talking a few decades here
the next empire that would the next
Emperor who would have constrained over
the entire Roman Empire would be
Constantine and at least relative to
Christians he would be the opposite of
Diocletian because as he's trying to
consolidate his power in 312 C II you
have the famous Battle of mill at the
Milvian bridge outside of or entering
into Rome and in this battle Constantine
he sees a vision of the Christian cross
centered on the Sun and he thinks that
that is a sign that he should fight
under the cross and he gets and he gets
the symbols painted on his soldiers
field and he's victorious and this date
312 milling the Milvian bridge the
battle at Milvian bridge is viewed as
the beginning of Constantine's
conversion to Christianity viewing it as
the phase chosen faith in 313 the he the
Roman Emperor or the Empire issues the
Edict of Milan which officially makes
Christianity okay it legalized as
Christianity which is a big deal because
these folks have been persecuted all
this time they haven't been worshipping
the Roman gods then in 325 Constantine
goes even further and he convenes the
Council of Nicaea
he brings the bishops from all of
Christendom together to start having a
more unified belief system they come up
with an IC and Creed a lot of the debate
is whether Jesus as son of God should be
considered equal to God or as God or a
little less as being the son maybe if
he's the son maybe there was a time
where there wasn't a son and there was
just God but the Nicene Creed says no
they are one and the same these two
things are equivalent and then
Constantine on his deathbed famously
gets baptized and becomes a Christian
the first Christian Emperor of this
gigantic Roman Emperor Empire and so you
can imagine you have more and more
followers of Christianity but now this
is supposed to speak primetime the
Emperor of the Roman the Emperor of the
Roman Empire has converted to
Christianity and it's a okit's it's a
legalized religion and then that gets
even more momentum when we get to the
end of the 4th century Emperor
Theodosius who was Christian under him
it becomes the official religion of the
Roman Empire the same Empire that at one
point Christianity was illegal and it
was being persecuted now it was the
official religion of the Roman Empire
and Theodosius I mentioned him in other
videos he was incidentally also the last
emperor to rule over both eastern and
western Roman empires so you have this
empire that starts off very
anti-christian actually in the beginning
they don't really really take much note
of what's going on in Judea and Galilee
but more and more they start to
persecute them but we go a few hundred
years into this and it becomes a
Christian Empire